Your boss’ office, his name etched onto
the frosted-glass window in the door, sitting
at the end of a long hallway.
He called you in, and you don’t know if
you’ll be leaving with your job.
A grimy public bathroom filled with graffiti,
spiders, cracked toilet seats, and a sinister
shadow in the very last stall.
A surgical theatre, where masked doctors wait
with gleaming scalpels, forceps, and bone
saws, preparing for an operation that you
don’t know if you’ll wake up from.
All of these have one thing in common: They’re
rooms that inspire dread.
But after this video, you’ll look back on
all of them like you would your cozy childhood
bedroom.
A wise man once said, “Life has many doors.”
What he didn’t say is that sometimes, opening
the wrong door can be a way of bringing that
life to an untimely end, or worse.
Especially when you’re dealing with the
kind of horrifying anomalies secured and contained
by the SCP Foundation.
You may think it’s what’s lurking inside
the room that might be your biggest threat,
but that’s a potentially lethal assumption.
Sometimes, the most dangerous thing is the
room itself.
And that’s what we’re here to talk about
today: Seven of the most terrifying rooms
on the Foundation’s database, none of which
have ever been featured on this channel before.
So reach out, grab the handle, and open the
door.
Welcome to the SCP Foundation’s most terrifying
rooms.
All you can do is hope that, by the end, you’ll
actually be able to leave.
We’ll begin with an old classic from Series
One: SCP-002, a maleficent meatball known
as The “Living” Room.
There’s a decent chance you’re sitting
in your living room right now while you watch
this video, so you may be thinking, “What’s
so wrong about that?”
But this really is a living room, and it’s
always on the lookout for some tasteful new
furniture.
From the outside, SCP-002 appears to be a
huge, tumorous blob made out of living flesh.
Sure, that may seem off-putting, but don’t
be so superficial.
The inside of 002 is a different story.
It may appear like your standard low-rent
apartment from within, but this place has
a lot of personality.
There’s a single window, despite there being
no opening for a window from the outside.
In addition to all the standard furniture
- chairs, tables, a TV stand - it’s actually
developed a number of other wonderful amenities
since being contained by the Foundation, including
two lamps, a throw rug, a television, a radio,
a beanbag chair, three books in an unknown
language, four children's toys, and a small
potted plant.
The first thing you might notice about the
room is the funny smell.
Then, you might take a closer look at all
that lovely furniture.
That’s when you’ll realize that every
single piece of furniture in there is made
out of human tissue - wood is polished and
varnished bone, fabrics are woven from human
hair, leather is made from tanned human skin.
This is what happens to anyone who enters
SCP-002.
And sadly, if you’ve gotten close enough
to see this, it’s already too late.
We hope you enjoy the rest of your existence...as
a brand new armchair.
But maybe you don’t want to get turned into
furniture inside a living room within a giant
tumor.
Maybe you’ve got more specific needs: You
like puzzles, exercises, and most of all,
solitude.
You like to test your mental and physical
fortitude, without worrying about the distractions
caused by having to deal with other human
beings.
If that sounds like you, then let’s get
your feet wet and tell you about a wonderful
piece of prime real estate you can find Under
the Sea: SCP-057.
This underwater chamber is almost impossible
to get to without a James Cameron-style mini-submarine,
but believe us, it’s worth the effort.
If you manage to access SCP-057 and enter
its submerged chamber, then you’re going
to be treated to the best, last challenge
of your life.
The door will close behind you, permanently,
ensuring that wonderful privacy you so covet.
Then, the walls - these impenetrable monoliths
of slate-covered stone - will begin to move.
Like a kind of high-stakes game show, you’ll
need to keep moving, avoiding the ever-shifting
walls as the environment around you becomes
more and more disorienting.
There is no escape, only survival - and survival
is only temporary.
When your body fails you, or your mind snaps
under the weight of sustained mortal terror,
that’s when those walls will close in.
The monoliths of SCP-057 will get closer,
and closer, and closer...until your body is
crushed between them, killing you with a torturously
slow squeeze where nothing and nobody will
ever hear your final choked screams.
But it’s all worth it for that glorious
ocean view!
Look at all those adorable little fishies!
But hey, maybe seapunk isn’t your favorite
aesthetic.
Maybe you’re the more industrial type.
You couldn’t feel more at home than among
a complex network of anomalous pipes.
We’ll admit, that’s eerily specific, but
it isn’t half as eerie as SCP-015.
If ever you find yourself opening the door
to the main room of a certain undisclosed
warehouse, you’ll feel like you’ve walked
into an early 2000s screensaver with a decidedly
gritty edge: An impossibly huge and intricate
mass of pipes, vents, boilers, and other various
plumbing apparatus, that just keeps growing,
seemingly becoming more strange and anomalous
as it does so.
These pipes have been made out of bone, wood,
steel, pressed ash, human flesh, glass, and
granite.
There aren’t any pipes made out of traditional
pipe-making materials, like lead, copper,
ceramics, or PVC.
And if you think what the pipes are made of
is weird, the materials that travel through
them are even freakier.
These include oil, mercury, rats, a species
of insect not yet identified, ground glass,
seawater, entrails, and molten iron.
And this is important to remember because
if you appear hostile to SCP-015, or enter
the room carrying tools, the pipes will begin
to burst and spray you with their contents
in self-defense.
Resulting in one of the few times in human
history where you’d be incredibly lucky
to only be sprayed with rats or human entrails.
Much like SCP-173, the Sculpture, it’s important
to keep this room under strict observation.
It’s when the pipes are left unoccupied
that they start expanding, and trying to grow
downwards, in hopes of mixing with the sewer
system below.
If ever that happens, then the pipes may end
up coming to a room near you.
And considering that people have also reported
screaming coming from inside the pipes, what
comes out of them may not even be as frightening
as what could be going in...
But maybe you don’t want a warehouse.
Perhaps you just want to rent a small, cozy
room in a one-story building over in Weehawken,
New Jersey.
Problem is, if you try to do this, you might
end up lodging in SCP-5256, a room that defies
reality in a number of freaky ways thanks
to its prior occupant: A highly unstable reality
warper.
The reality filters get stronger the further
you go into the room, with the terminus being
the room’s far corner, which presents as
an empty void that’s impossible to even
see.
A damaged bloody hammer is lodged into the
far wall.
Metal fragments covered in human blood float
near the entrance.
Half-eaten bugs all over the floor.
There’s a crucifix on the wall, along with
medical-grade anesthetics with trace amounts
of neural tissue inside.
All evidence points to the reality warper
having been the victim of atrocious and inhumane
acts, perhaps as a way to “cure” it of
its anomalous affliction.
And to add to the creep factor, many believe
its body is still there, lurking in the unseeable
corner.
How do we know?
Because despite the corner of the room being
unseeable, people have still performed simple
tactile tests by sticking their hands into
the space.
One D-Class reported it feeling like leathery
flesh with occasional scraps of fabric, and
sharp needle-like objects occasionally sticking
out of its skin.
But for rent this cheap, who can really complain
about a body or two?
But that’s enough about things that are
just creepy, let’s get dangerous instead.
A room that won’t just freak you out with
some eerie anomalous sights.
If you get unlucky, it’ll give you a horrifying
death.
After all, who doesn’t like a little excitement?
Step into SCP-4595, a small room in a woodshed
behind an abandoned house near Jasper, Indiana.
You’ll be taken in by its rustic charm at
first.
It’s a quiet, peaceful setting, where you’re
alone with your thoughts.
When the room was first found, it contained
a small, bloodstained shovel and the skeleton
of an adolescent male.
But don’t let that put you off.
Don’t let the charcoal marking of the word
“WITCH” written on the exterior door bother
you either.
It all just adds to the character of the room.
Oh, though there’s one thing we should probably
mention: There is an entity, known as SCP-4595-A,
that lives a meter beneath the room.
She’s a witch-like creature, rotted and
covered in wounds on her torso and face.
Her mere presence will instill a sense of
paranoia and dread into you, getting worse
and worse the longer you’re in there.
But stay quiet about it.
If at any point, you disturb SCP-4595, all
the empty spaces in your chest cavity, as
well as your lungs, airways, stomach, and
intestine, will suddenly fill with live desert
locusts, causing you to experience a horrible
death.
So be a considerate upstairs neighbor.
Or else.
So, remember when we said earlier that it’s
not always what’s inside the room that can
cause you harm?
Sometimes, it’s the thing right on the other
side of the door.
Look at the nearest closed door.
Really focus on it.
Tell us, how can you be so sure there’s
not something on the other side?
Can’t you hear its heavy, wheezing breaths?
It’s not a home invader, it’s something
even worse: SCP-303, and it can make any room,
anywhere, an absolute nightmare for you.
Keep an eye on that door while we explain.
SCP-303 is a tall, emaciated creature with
dark skin and no face, just a giant mouth,
twisted into a fixed grimace of pain, with
unnaturally long teeth.
Nobody has ever seen its full body, but everyone
afflicted with its anomalous effects somehow
has an innate knowledge of exactly what they’re
dealing with.
The amount of time that 303 spends behind
the door seems to be random, but whenever
it appears, people will be afflicted with
such a level of raw, paralytic terror, that
they physically cannot bear to open the door
while it’s still there.
This is one thing if it’s hiding inside
a broom closet, but if you’re trapped in
a room with only one exit, and 303 manifests
behind it, you’re in real trouble.
As the number of people who’ve died of dehydration
and starvation in totally normal rooms, while
boxed in by 303, have found out - When you’re
dealing with this monster, any room can be
a nightmare.
But while 303 is no doubt scary, it’s not
quite as mind-melting as SCP-970, the final
anomalous room on this list.
Much like 303, it involves doors, and rather
than being fixed to a single location, it
can appear in theoretically any room.
Known as The Recursive Room, stepping through
this door will lead to a copy of the room
you were just inside.
A little trippy, but not exactly pure nightmare
fuel.
But much like how a photocopier will slowly
create distortions if the same image is copied
repeatedly, the more rooms in the recursive
room’s sequence that one cycles through,
the more distorted each one gets.
Eventually, the rooms will begin to display
visuals straight out of your worst nightmares.
Foundation Researchers who sent a drone through
a six-hour sequence of recursive rooms ended
up being discharged to undergo psychiatric
treatment, after seeing their own mutilated
corpses in the rooms.
A cruel trick, or a deadly premonition of
things to come in a darker possible future?
Either way, these unfortunate researchers
couldn’t get their experience in the Recursive
Room out of their heads.
But we’re sure you’ll have a more pleasant
time…
There you have it, folks: Some of the most
terrifying rooms that the SCP Foundation is
aware of.
Let us know which one was your favorite down
in the comments.
And of course, be careful - if these are the
ones the Foundation has in containment, imagine
the ones that are still out there, waiting
to be discovered.
For all you know, it could only be one door
away...
Now go check out “SCP-2317 - The Devourer
of Worlds / A Door to Another World” and
“SCP-5049 - The Skin Salesman - Demon Dan's
Discount Homunculus Depot” for more anomalous
doors that should never be opened!